DEMOCRACY WILL CONTINUE.
AND THAT'S ALL WE CAN HANG OUR
HATS ON.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE FOR.
>> AND, S.E., LET'S SWITCH GEARS
HERE.
NEW JERSEY CONGRESSMAN DONALD
PAYNE JR. CALLED OUT REPUBLICANS
ON HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI'S
HUSBAND AT THEIR HOME IN SAN
FRANCISCO FRIDAY.
HERE'S WHAT HE TWEETED.
THEY WERE SHOUTING WHERE'S NANCY
WHETHER THEY STORMED THE
CAPITOL.
GOP LEADER, YOU AND EVERY HOUSE
GOP MEMBER MUST PUBLICLY CONDEMN
THIS VIOLENT ATTACK, A HORRIFIC
CRIME HAS TAKEN PLACE.
YOUR SILENCE SENDS THE MESSAGE
THIS IS ACCEPTABLE.
DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE COME OUT
FORCEFULLY ENOUGH IN THE HOUSE
TO DENOUNCE WHAT OCCURRED?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> AND WHY IS THAT?
>> WHEN IT COMES TO POLITICAL
RHETORIC AND POLITICAL
EXTREMISM.
WE KNOW HOW CORRUPTING POLITICS
HAS BEEN IN OUR CULTURE AND
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES SPECIFICALLY, THEY'RE A
DRUG, AND WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
AN EPIDEMIC.
THEY ARE A MIND ALTERING
SUBSTANCE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TRAJECTORY
OF SOMEONE LIKE LARA LOGAN AND
THE ABSOLUTE BILE COMING OUT OF
HER MOUTH, YOU CAN ALMOST CHART
THE RABBIT HOLE SHE FELL INTO.
AND SHE'S NOT ALONE.
I MEAN, THIS IS METASTASIZED IN
OUR ELECTORATE.
WHEN YOU AND I TALK ABOUT QANON
AND PEDOPHILE RINGS AND JFK JR.
COMING BACK FROM THE DEAD, THEY
SOUND CRAZY AND ABSURD TO US.
BUT TO OTHERS THEY ARE REAL.
SOME GO AHEAD AND ACT OUT ON
THEM VIOLENTLY IN SOME CASES.
AND THAT'S -- THAT'S SOME OF THE
DAMAGE.
THE OTHER DAMAGE IS IN FAMILIES.
I MEAN, SOME PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY CUT OFF FROM FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS BECAUSE OF THEIR
IRRATIONAL THINKING.
AND I WISH THAT VOTING WERE THE
SIMPLE SOLUTION TO THIS.
OUR VOTING DOES NOT MAKE THIS GO
AWAY.
THIS IS AN ABSOLUTE CANCER.
AND I'M WORRIED THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GET A LOT MORE OF IT BECAUSE
POLITICAL LEADERS ARE NOT TAKING
THIS ON.
REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED TO
COURT QANON BECAUSE THEY SAID
THEY LIKED DONALD TRUMP.
REPUBLICANS HAVE DECIDED TO GIVE
COMFORT TO THESE KINDS OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT CAN
MANIFEST